this episode is sponsored by card fight
vanguard overdress card fight vanguard
overdress is a new anime animated by
kinema citrus with original character
designs by clamp that is airing right
now it follows the story of 15 year old
yuyu condo a shy young boy who discovers
the training card game card fights
vanguard for the first time through a
charts encounter with megami okuda there
he finds out about team blackout a group
of players where he's invited to join
and so starts yuyu kondo's journey into
card fight vanguard where he learns how
to play the game overcome his
insecurities and take on other skilled
players in the game this is a new anime
perfect for any card game fans looking
for a new show and well also if you
already maybe play card fight vanguard
actually i don't know if you'd be
interested this sounds like the anime
for you the second season is out right
now episodes are available in japanese
with english subtitles on the official
card fight vanguard youtube channel with
an english dub coming soon that's right
you can watch the anime for free on the
official card fight vanguard youtube
channel as well as on other platforms so
click the link in the description if you
want to start watching today thank you
to card 5 vanguard overdress and with
that said on with the video want to hear
a joke
league of legends
is good
actually i kind of mean it
for as long as i can remember league of
legends has been the punching bag of the
gaming community and beyond other gamers
would make fun of league players anime
fans would make fun of league players my
technologically illiterate grandma would
make fun of league players league
players would make fun of league players
league of legends was and still is the
butt of every cheap joke because well
imagine actually being a [ __ ] league
of legends player
says the league of legends player
however as that [ __ ] league of
legends player myself there's always
been one thing i could wholeheartedly
say was so cool about the game
pretty much everything that didn't have
to do with playing the game in the past
i've made it pretty clear that i'm a
pretty big fan of the esports scene but
another thing that always went hard were
the god damn cinematics
[Music]
i still get chills watching some of
these man from the direction to the
music to the cinematography league
cinematics was so good they almost make
the game look playable for the longest
time a lot of us have even made jokes
that riot should just go ahead and make
their own anime i mean it's so anime
that even hiroyuki sawano has done a
soundtrack for them already you see the
cinematics and you're like jesus this is
giving me goosebumps and then you see
kda you're like damn this is catchy as
hell and then you watch the east wards
you're like oh my god this is the hypest
game ever and then you play the game and
it's like
are you goddamn [ __ ] kidding me
oh yeah
that's why it sucks to play league
everything outside of the game would
push me to play it and then everything
in the game would push me to not at this
point i don't even play league i just
enjoy consuming league content so when
riot games finally announced that they
were making a league tv series i was
excited finally something else to keep
me occupied with league without actually
having to play it all i wanted was some
cool cinematic fan service for some of
my favorite characters maybe some cool
action scenes here and there to turn my
brain off for some simple popcorn fun
what i didn't expect was
one of the best things i've watched all
year arcane may just redefine what video
game adaptations can be and so far i've
only seen a few people outside of the
gaming community talk about it when i
feel this is something that everyone
should be talking about so i'm gonna
take that step i realize this is a bit
out of my comfort zone and a lot of you
are probably gonna be like but giggle
this is isn't anime you're not allowed
to talk about it oh yeah well what if i
watched it on japanese netflix in japan
like this
you're just watching animation that
comes from japan i'm in japan and
watching animation we are not the same
so first things first you do not need to
know a single thing about league of
legends to enjoy arcane i repeat you
don't need to know [ __ ] all about league
to enjoy this show the problem with so
many video game adaptations is that the
creators come in with the attitude of
yeah we already know you know this guy
and this guy you're just here to see
them do the thing and if you know the
game you're like oh they did the thing
it's the thing and if you don't know the
game you're like
who the [ __ ] are any of these people
arcane from the get-go doesn't seem to
know anything about league or its world
it goes you'll care about these
characters because we're gonna make you
care about these characters not because
these are champions in a game
oh and sometimes you also see them do
the thing it's the thing welcome to
piltover a glorious city celebrating
progress and innovation fueled by the
genius miners who pushed the boundaries
of science arts and craftsmanship this
is a place anyone would want to live in
it's a steampunk paradise with
mechanical blimps hoverboards and
magical gates however sitting just below
is the undercity the dark gritty
netherworld where gangs rule the streets
substance abuse is out of control and
its inhabitants are on a daily fight for
survival overlooked and ignored by those
prospering above i love a series where
it feels like the world is taking place
in has existed far before the series
starts and will continue to exist far
after the story is finished being told
and this is what i immediately felt as
soon as the opening shots revealed just
where this story was about to take place
[Music]
arcane drops you in this completely new
world and instantly starts the gears
turning you sense this attention to
detail that makes it truly feel like
you've been transported into a living
breathing world you feel the fresh
sunlight brush against your skin basking
over piltover streets you smell the
stench of fresh garbage walking down the
alleyways of the undercity both sides
have their own rules their own culture
their own inhabitants this is a rich
world that the story is not just told in
it's lived in these aren't places built
to service the characters we're about to
follow these characters stories are the
results of this world's foundations we
follow various storylines surrounding
the people living in this city a sister
duo fighting to survive in the rough
life of the undercity an ambitious young
scientist bent on making the world a
better place at any cost a divided city
on the verge of war against itself when
people try to sell you a show they
normally try to boil it down to a
sentence elevator pitch or one gripping
plot hook but i can't really do that
with arcane because it's not really a
show that hurts you it's one that
immerses you you have these different
characters doing their own thing in the
world individual storyline and plot
threads that occasionally pass converge
and eventually crash into each other i
really hate using this comparison but if
i dumb down the structure it's kind of
like what
game of thrones did all right there i
said the thing what we have here is a
character-driven conflict set in the
backdrop of a world full of different
elements it's not a story that's new or
revolutionary but it doesn't need to be
when it does what it does so [ __ ]
well one thing i never really thought
about when it came to adapting a video
game is that i always thought that
having a roster as wide and varied as
league's one was would make it harder to
focus on the people that mattered and
create interesting characters that we
could actually care about and take
seriously if you weren't already a fan
of the game turns out you can turn that
into a strength when it comes to video
game rosters one of the big challenges
is being able to design unique
characters that can be easily
distinguished from each other which
we've seen to varying degrees of success
i mean just look at dragon ball fighters
half this ross i swear to god it's just
a [ __ ] goku nft and one thing i can
actually compliment ligon is that
despite having over 150 champions riot
has done an excellent job in designing
distinct characters that not only look
different but play and feel thematically
unique
most of the time now in the video game
what this means is that you have a bunch
of wacky larger-than-life champions that
are all actually very distinct in their
characterization and personality and it
just so happens that this is actually
the perfect recipe to have an array of
very interesting characters in your
character-driven drama like in-game
you've got someone like jinx he's just
your basic t he xt i'm not like other
girls whose basic characterization boils
down to discount harley quinn with a
gatling gun arcane took this basic
concept and showed us an innocent girl
who just wanted to be loved someone who
wanted to help to be accepted but
couldn't help but cursing everything she
touches to the point where everyone she
ever loves eventually dies or abandons
her the more she tries the more she
jinxes her own life and everyone around
her and the further she slips away from
the edge of sanity until eventually the
young innocent girl who just wanted to
be loved is no more and she's just one
of the champions we find out the
backstory of i'm not saying riot's done
a bad job at characterization in their
games there's just only so much you can
do with a few voice lines and a wacky
design so what i find so impressive
about arcane is how it's able to take
these champions with wacky
larger-than-life elements and turn them
into very human characters with
compelling backstories there are a lot
of video games out there that we don't
realize have extremely cliche stories or
characters because they're just there
for the gameplay and hey if their design
looks cool who the hell gives a crap i
mean i didn't give a [ __ ] about league
lore did you give a [ __ ] about league
lore arcane goes that extra mile to
really humanize its cast these are no
longer archetypes these feel like real
people i think one of the best things is
that there's no real distinction between
a champion in the game and a
non-champion character in the series the
same care and attention was put into
every single person in the show so much
so that i begin to question if some of
these characters were actually going to
turn into champions because some of them
have equally interesting stories and
riot how are you going to make me
invested in all these people when i
can't even play them or spend money on
their skins they never felt like there
was a pressure to give more attention to
ex person or why person because they
were a champion in the game and this
really nailed down the feeling that all
these champions just started off as
normal people they aren't special or
compelling because they're playable
characters in a video game they're
compelling characters because they are
compelling characters which is why i
feel that people who have zero knowledge
about league might even enjoy this more
because they can just appreciate the
characters for what they are instead of
subconsciously trying to figure out who
is who or who is going to turn into who
all right what's next
[Music]
oh yeah
it looks [ __ ] great
as a weeb a big reason into why i got
enticed by anime is that i got bored of
the animation industry shifting towards
the same pixar ask 3d animation well
that doesn't mean i can't appreciate
when something like into the
spider-verse comes along and i feel like
arcane has done just that for a tv
animated series this [ __ ] is movie level
quality and beyond whether it just be
during a normal scene or one of the
kick-ass action scenes i might not have
expected the amazing story but riot has
already proved that they can do amazing
action-packed cinematics but even with
that high bar arcane took it even
further i actually think it should be
illegal for anything league related to
go this [ __ ] hard combined with some
of the fantastic music i'm pretty sure
anyone with a nut allergy within a
three-mile radius of me was in danger of
going into anaphylactic shock because i
nudded so hard everything about this
production seems like it was given so
much care and attention but by far the
most exciting thing about all this is
that
this could just be the start arcane
takes place in one tiny corner of league
one little piece in its world looking at
the different regions you have
characters that come from a snow kingdom
a pirate haven a kingdom of egyptian
gods you've got ninjas and samurais and
even a lovecraftian horror dimension i'm
a sucker for fictional worlds that can
successfully combine different
fantastical elements into a coherent
universe and the biggest thing that
arcane has made me realize is that
league has a really [ __ ] interesting
universe piltover was already an
incredibly interesting place and we've
already foreshadowed the region of noxus
but combined with the other regions we
know out there exist there are so many
possibilities for interesting stories in
completely unique settings with distinct
characters and on top of all that
there's the possibility for all these
different worlds to collide with each
other it's one of the few places where a
cinematic universe wouldn't just feel
like a tacton element because the
cinematic universe is basically what
summoner's rift is right now arcane is i
think not only the best video game
adaptation of all time but has the
potential to grow into one of the most
exciting fictional franchises of the
modern day right easily could have
settled for making a quick cash grab and
giving us some cheap fan service but
what they've made here is an absolute
master class it's hard enough to write a
series with a single interesting story
for a single interesting character but
arcade manages to do that for multiple
characters and manages to balance all
these people without feeling like anyone
was getting too much individual
attention while weaving all their
individual stories into a compelling
overarching narrative it's not fast and
it's not slow all nine episodes feel
perfectly paced with twists and turns
right until the end because holy [ __ ]
there are only a few times when i finish
a show and it leaves me speechless but
that's exactly what happened when the
credits rolled when the season ended
arcane may just do something i thought
could never happen
make league of legends respected what
ride have done here is nothing short of
incredible and it deserves to be enjoyed
by league fans gaming fans anime fans or
just fans of good [ __ ] and i can't wait
to see what comes next you know what
maybe league of legends wasn't so bad
after all
all right league sucks again
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much to alpha sigma basil
dysfunctional degenerate elephant aivito
jeff levardos manopla payne patchett
pony stark walto and everyone else my
patreon for helping to make this video
possible okay guys i swear i still watch
anime i swear to god i know it's been a
while since i've made like purely anime
content on a single show but i swear to
god i'm still watching anime alright
there is definitely going to be an end
of year video covering all the anime
that i've watched that's why i haven't
made so many videos on just singular
shows because now's the end of the year
and i've got to do my top 10 or top 20
or whatever i'm gonna do for the end of
the year video so keep an eye out for
that because it is december and that's
the type of video that i work on in that
month anyway though that's it from me no
further updates today i've been gigguk
and i'll see you all next time